It's time for, pop quiz!
(crowd cheering)
(bell ringing)
All right, Sharon Nicki, you have been selected.
(crowd applauding)
Come on down!
She looks so cute and you coordinate with Drew and I.
All right so right over here.
Yes!
We inspire you to shimmy!
All right if you correctly answer the questions
about today's show, you'll win
one thousand dollars!
(crowd cheering)
And the good news is if you answer one it's a hundred,
and you answer two it's 200, you know?
So if you could win something.
Okay all right I'm ready.
Let's do it.
Okay. First question.
Jaleel White played Urkel on Family Matters.
What was his catch phrase?
"Did I do that?"
And he had that very famous catchphrase.
Did I do that?
(crowd applauding)
And we just wanted to hear you say it too.
Okay question number two,
Chef Anne Burrell,
she had a go a phrase, "mise en place"
What language was it in
Oh mise en?
Can I give you a hint? Can I give her a hint?
Oh it sounds like French.
Mise en place is a French term,
and it means "put in place."
(crowd cheering)
And the final question is,
Newsweek recommends that you sleep in what,
for a better night's sleep?
Naked!
Next, if you like to sleep naked as the day you were born,
apparently the writers at Newsweek want you to go for it.
(crowd cheering)
You win one thousand dollars!
(crowd applauding)
Thank you!
Look it!
(crowd cheering)
Thank you so much for playing.
Thank you!
(upbeat music)